at first I didn't think was a big deal
because I've been thinking about it over
over the last couple of years and it
doesn't really bother me until my
brother so we're you know I did his show
and my mother and I were hanging out and
no we were at parks barbecue and my
brother goes yeah man they're
disrespecting you did you know Steve
doesn't write who the [ __ ]
disrespecting me high school did your
high school is disrespecting you did I
go you mean the school I went to Poway
high he goes yeah dude you're not on the
Poway high school
Hall of Fame yeesh and I go I don't care
about that like why would I give a [ __ ]
he goes it's disrespectful dude it's
about ethics see what's right or wrong
and stuff like that and then I started
sweating I go you're [ __ ] right he
convinced you yeah it's about the
ethical quality of the situation and he
goes look at it so he go to power high
school's Alumni page and I honest I
honestly have tried to be like sensible
about it right to go okay maybe the
people on this list right are way more
famous than me and I get it because if
it had like Matthew McConaughey right
yeah what's a magician's name David
David Blaine Yeah right right if they
had anything like that yeah Bill Clinton
magician bill Bill Clinton that's a good
one you know what we're up shaving this
one gabby-gabz logician I was good so
Bill Clinton so you go you know I would
if those names were on it I'd be like
yeah [ __ ] em I'm for [ __ ] sick
comedian who is a [ __ ] right but we
googled every [ __ ] game did you
really oh yeah we googled every name on
it right and I couldn't in my head
figure out why they got on to this
honorable list and me and Tom DeLonge
from blink-182 went to my school he's
not on it he's not I'm not on it and
what I realize is that the only people
they nominate are people with Christian
values what are we doing baby oh no I'm
having some gastrointestinal upset and I
think I might have just mouthed burped
oh I'm so sorry
it's fine babe all right but I'm gonna
rent right now that's not all [ __ ]
burps during my rants all right woman
I'm sorry
so anyway we and then he then I started
getting rage eyes when my brother was
like see who's this guy
like click on somebody yeah we have
Justin Woodruff okay what is he from
1996 what do you do obviously is one of
the most well known orthopedic surgeon
specialists in Arizona wait and you are
who Bobby
that's impressive he fixes human body
yeah but I'm telling you right now is he
the only dude that does that but you
fixed human hearts and minds and feet
Dreamweaver I'm a Dreamweaver
all right I create cascades of magic
mentally with my words you know it
people top on clouds and they live in
the nether world through my through our
joy do you understand what I'm saying
George actually I could have said it
differently and didn't make any sense
what I said but you get what I'm saying
exactly all right so I'm asking tiger
barely listeners to do a simple thing I
think we should get sick no you can go
to the paui High School Alumni Hall of
Fame website Poway hilum night or God or
nominate a candidate you can nominate a
candidate and I want everyone to fill
out this form right I want hundreds of
thousands of nominations for both Tom
and Bob first me though where's Bobby
yeah first do me and if you have time do
Tom DeLonge as well hey if they don't
cept you what picture did your you had
up your picture end up in the wrong high
school yearbook maybe you'll end up in
their Hall of Fame oh yeah yes okay all
right so I don't know if you guys know
this but my senior year at Perry high
school I you know we got our yearbook at
the end of the year there was a mixup
and they didn't have my photo in the
senior year you know and I went to the
administration I go um because I was
really sensitive about it it was
devastating and I go um what and what is
he gonna recall they don't give a [ __ ]
and they go oh wow we'll do some
investigating what is George doing there
and so thank you and so then there was a
school called Mount Carmel that was like
all Filipinos right and there was like
40 percent Filipinos I went to that
school
super Asian because they live in a town
called Penasquitos and there's a lot of
Latinos that live in Penasquitos I ended
up in their yearbook but it was at 5 if
I did some research I'll tell you it was
the same photography company and I bet
your money they looked at the pile of
poly high oh we had a mix-up and they
just put my [ __ ] head shot or
whatever space here yeah yeah and they
just put it so I'm in the Penasquitos
hold on then we could theoretically
nominate you for both schools and see
which one takes you yeah theoretically
yes but you power high go first because
you know I took classes you know Tommy
high school was the school were after I
graduated they had a key they were the
kid was allowed to go to school saying
that being gay is a sin right and you
you know and he wore the shirt around
campus and the administration was ok
with it
you know man this is same so I believe
that they nominate people based on a
Christian value value system but it's a
public [ __ ] school right it's not a
Christian school right and I could argue
in court that I'm more famous than at
least 40% of the people that aren't
[ __ ] on that list dude if you took
this to court it would be amazing I
might that's how my brother got me
all riled up he got me seeing red man
hey I'm gonna say this too and I went to
Chris D'Elia I went to Whitney Cummings
I went to every comic I could and I made
my case you should call your agent
I'm gonna call CIA yeah I made my case
and I said is this something that I
should make us think about you know what
they said oh you said yes you know how
we went and had a big conference with
your agents and your reps at CAA yeah
should have brought it up then as a like
top priority from on their list by the
way I'm glad Kyla went why because you
were able to sit in this gigantic
boardroom with a bunch of suits taking
notes your reps are lovely people they
are lovely people I love them okay good
I love them so kind and sweet and open
and they they they put up with you what
did you see me stand up and take take
charge I saw you you didn't even let
them like open with a sentence you know
what I feel what happened I just stood
up and I'd made I did a monologue I
don't know what I want this is what I
don't want yeah you can't change my mind